what I want to do in this video is step
through the program that we wrote in the
previous video to really understand
what's happening line by line and get a
little bit of an intuitive understanding
for for loops and variables we're going
to do it for a specific example we're
gonna do it an example where the user
input so when it when the user is
prompted to input a number the user will
input the number 3 we're just going to
assume that and I've picked a low number
so that we don't have to keep looping
through this forever so this video can
be of a reasonable length so right when
that happens when the user inputs the
number 3 it assigns the variable number
to be equal to 3 and there's two ways
that you can think about this I tend to
when I do in any programming language
when I think of a variable I tend to
view it as a bucket so I have a bucket
called number I have a bucket called
number and in that bucket when the user
inputs a 3 if the user inputs a 3 I'm
sticking a 3 in that bucket Python is a
little bit different than some languages
and the the more correct way and and and
they're both kind of intuitive I think
if you think about it viewing a variable
in Python is to think of the variable as
referring to referring to the 3 and I
say that because in Python if you change
a variables let's say right under this
we wrote number is equal to 2 we didn't
do that but if we said number is equal
to what Python does is that she leaves
that 3 there in memory and then it would
then point to the number 2 it would then
point to the number 2 instead it
wouldn't obliterate the 3 and just put a
2 there the 3 still exists and that's
important when we start doing I guess
more complex or nuanced things with with
more fancy datatypes but let's rewind
all of this for the sake of this program
you can view it either way a bucket with
a 3 in it or you could view it as a
label that is referring to a 3 some
place in in the computer's memory now
the next thing that happens is that we
have another variable called product and
we assign product to be equal to 1 so
I'm going to do this the same two
representations so we've set up another
bucket here called product and we are
signing we are putting 1 in that bucket
or you could say that product is product
is a variable it's a label that is
referring to a 1 and then and then we
get to our for loop and this is probably
the confusing part so we have for I in
range of number and number in this case
so literally the interpret say okay
what's number well in this case number
is 3 so this is going to be evaluated as
range of 3 this is going to be evaluated
as range of 3 in our particular example
range of 3 and once again how did the
interpreter know that it's a range of
number numbers a variable look up the
number variable okay 3 sitting in it so
I'm going to put a 3 right there or look
up the number variable the number
variable is pointing to the number 3 so
I'm just going to put a 3 here and take
a range of 3 and we saw in the last
video that if you evaluate just range of
3 range of 3 is equal to is equal to a
sequence of numbers 0 1 2 so it creates
a sequence of 3 numbers starting at 0 up
to that number minus 1 and what the for
loop does is every time we go through
the for loop it executes this code it
executes this code that's inside the for
loop and we know it's inside the for
loop because we indented it
we indented it in the convention the
most-used convention is python is 2 you
don't use the tab you would press space
4 times and that that tells the
interpreter anything at this level of
indention happens every time we go
through the for loop and and when we
start the for loop the I variable is
going to start at 0 so the first time we
go through the for loop I is going to be
the first element in this sequence then
when we go through the for loop again
I is going to be the second element in
the sequence and then when we go through
the for loop again I is going to be the
third element in the sequence and then
we go to the for loop and it'll try to
assign I to another element to the
sequence and say hey wait there are no
more elements in the sequence and then
it'll break out of the for loop and then
continue on with the rest of the program
so given that let's think about what
happens for the particular example where
the user inputted
a 3 so range of number is going to
evaluate as I wrote it up here 0 1 to 0
let me let me do it this way let me
over here so it's going to be zero zero
one two and the first time into through
the loop I so I'm gonna use this
convention right over here the first
time through the loop I is going to
refer to the zero or if we use this
convention over here the first time as
we go through the loop I you could view
it as a bucket that is going to be
assigned the first element of range of
three the first element of the sequence
it is going to be zero and then we
execute what's in the loop we assign we
reassign so we have reassigned product
to be something new right over here and
what is this something new the first
time we go through the for loop I is 0 0
plus 1 is 1 so this part the first time
we go through the loop let me do that a
color you can see the first time we go
through the loop this is going to be 1 0
plus 1 product is 1 product is 1 product
is 1 this first time we go through the
loop let me do the same colors so I is I
is 0 plus 1 so we get 1 1 times 1 is 1
so product will be assigned to be 1 so
product will be reassigned to be 1 which
really isn't gonna change anything
because it's already 1 so it was 1
before you multiply it by 1 and reassign
it to be 1 so I could write you know
cross out 1 it's not gonna be 1 again
but I'll just leave it as 1 or we can
just say it's gonna be reassigned to be
1 so nothing really has changed that
first time through the loop but now
interesting things are going to happen
so now we'll go back to the beginning of
the loop and now I will be the next
element in the loop so now I let me
delete this it will be it will be
reassigned to be the next element in the
loop so now I will be 1 now I will be 1
that's what the for loop does it makes I
each of the items in the sequence in
order going through them and now we
execute it again now now we go look at
product times I plus 1 product is still
1 I is now 1 so 1 plus 1 is now going to
be 2 is now going to be 2 so 1 times 2
is going to be our new product so the
product the new product it was 1
for now we're multiplying it by two and
assigning it again to product so the new
product is now going to be two so the
product variable is now two and then now
we go we try to loop again and now this
time I will be I will be the next
element I is going to be the next
element in the sequence I is going to be
the next element in the sequence right
over here or we could say I is going to
be reassigned to to the next element of
the sequence and we try to evaluate it
again so now we go into the for loop
product is now two product is now two I
is now 2 2 plus 1 is 3 so this whole
expression over here is 3 so we have two
product is now 2 times I plus 1 I plus 1
I is 2 so I plus 1 is 3 so if 2 times 3
is now going to be 6 so the new product
times I plus 1 is now 6 so this is now
this is now going to let me do that same
blue color this is now going to be this
is now going to be 6 and now we try to
execute the for loop again and the
formulas gonna say hey let me reassign I
let me reassign I to be the next the
next item in the sequence it tries to
find the next item in the sequence it
says wait there is no next item in the
sequence there is no next item of the
sequence so we're done executing our for
loop so there's nothing there's nothing
there's nothing left in our sequence so
we're done with our for loop now we
break out of it and we go to the next
line in the program so the next time the
program is literally just print the
product and at this point we just want
to output the product and the variable
product is now 6 the variable product is
now 6 and actually one thing I should
have done this entire time is I was
sticking with the bucket representation
but the product on this representation
here is started referring to one it got
reassigned to one but then it got
assigned to 2 so then this reference
went to 2 and then it got reassigned to
6 then it got reassigned to 6 so if I
were to be consistent with this
representation over here every
time product is referring to another
number or you can view it as a bucket
for the sake of this program where it
keeps getting reassigned and what was
cool about this is when we're done with
this for loop the the number that's
sitting in the bucket product the
variable product or you could say the
number that the variable product is
referring to is the factorial of the
number that the person inputted it's the
factorial of 3 and if you remember 3 the
symbol for factorial is that exclamation
mark is equal to 3 times 2 times 1